[Music]
Charlie get inside and wash your face
it's past your bedtime dad now I thought
you said this was your house girls time
to go thank you
when will this ever end Charlie you are
a monster every moment of your life
looks like the first two minutes of Law
and Order SVU you've convinced more
women to have abortions than the
prenatal tests for Down syndrome there
once was an old man named Ross who jokes
were covered with moss his punch line
was musty his premise was dusty I wished
him gonna exhaust me what
could I do Jess you Jeff City get
his life together Charlie went out on a
national comedy tour for every night
Charlie you walked on stage and you told
the audience you were a warlock from
Mars oh maybe you are but I'll tell you
what you're not a comedian from Earth if
you're winning then something's wrong
with the scoreboard
[Applause]
come on man Charlie if you're winning
then this must not be a child custody
hearing
only time your kids get to see you is in
reruns you're the black sheep of a
family responsible for three Mighty
Ducks movies speaking of things that
should already be dead Charlie Sheen is
still alive Charlie
you I'm a fan you were amazing in
platoon your marriage to Denise Richards
it was kind of like her Vietnam because
she was constantly afraid of being
killed by Charlie but there's no denying
how famous you are I mean it was
international news when you ruined the
lives of those two girls living with you
you know your daughters but no I mean
Charlie you get a bad rap but you're
just like Bruce Willis you know you were
big in the 80s and now you're old slots
being filled with Ashton Kutcher and Amy
Schumer great job you really me tonight
which I did because I'm into anonymous
sex and no one's more anonymous here
than Amy Schumer I mean I'm Charlie
Sheen they know me on Mars I personally
asked that William Shatner be here only
because I needed some clean urine I had
to bring it out of the diaper but it did
the job